you worked on 42 movies with woody can
you tell us a little bit about that
process how it started when you first
met what was the first movie until all
the way to today what is your shorthand
your collaboration and how you speak for
each other well I met woody I was
Marion's assistant on bananas and on
play it again Sam which he wrote but did
not direct but he was there he was
present and so I knew him but then
Marion left around 1973 74 to go to
produce movies with David picker and she
left me
he sort of running her business and I
think that woody was just she was so
socially uncomfortable back then and so
shy that I just don't think he wanted to
meet a new person so he went with me 22
well at that time I was about 25 or 6
but Marion later said well she
encouraged him to which I'm sure she did
but I do think that you know he he
didn't really like to meet new people
Bobby green hunts here he could say
that's probably true so I did love and
death and he was so shy that he would
not talk to the actors he had his line
producer Freddie Gallo interview them
and he sat in a rocking chair in the
back of Marion's Victorian living room
just watching and so that would that was
okay because Freddie was there as the
intermediary but then when I did Annie
Hall he came on his own and it was clear
that he expected me to kind of be at the
helm and again I was still you know it
may be my late 20s at this point I was
used to directors kind of taking charge
you know and and he sort of you know I
had to go into therapy actually
to learn how to take control of the room
I I didn't know I was supposed to do
that can you share with the rest of the
casting directors later what you learned
in therapy in therapy that'll be a good
thing a little extra special tonight but
of course you know obviously over the
years he's become socially more
comfortable and I've got a little more
confident but but you know it's funny
except in his in the documentary that
Barbara Kopple made about him wild man
blues he he kind of plays his own
persona in it and all the women in his
life do kind of boss him around and he
kind of likes it you know he kind of
likes it when you kind of take charge in
a funny way and he thinks it's funny but
I'd say that first of all I will have so
much I can say about him but but he's a
wonderful director to work with because
you can really say anything to him and
he you know there are directors who who
if you even really disagree with their
their idea for an actor you have to
really walk on eggshells because you
know they get kind of prickly and
sensitive and you could just say the
worst news - woody you're really good
and he would just he would he would just
be great he wanted to hear what you had
to say and so gradually over the years
it was really kind of an honor in a way
because our I think you know our
relationship was so sort of deep and we
did have a shorthand that it was became
a year-round conversation it wasn't just
the movie and he would tell me what he
was thinking of writing or he would send
me a script to see if I thought it was a
good thing right you're a true
collaborator and part of his process
really such an honor and such a really a
privilege and and then I would usually
the first time he sat down to see a
movie he put together he'd always asked
me to come sit with him and it was great
it was just great and again watching
that first cut I could you could say and
you didn't even have to mince word you
could say
that didn't work yeah oh and and he just
you know he would really listen to you
but he'd also kind of you could it
became a sort of humorous exchange in a
way you know